okay let's go ahead and start i think a
few more people will still drift in but
let's go ahead and start
um so as preliminaries um
so i've asked less to speak for about 35
to 40 minutes but he's
open to questions which are probably
best done by posting to the chat windows
and i'll
i'll interrupt the talk as i see as i
see fit
um and uh if you do post questions of
the chat windows reminder please post
them to be visible to both panelists and
attendees so that everyone
can see them and if you're an attendee
and want to get promoted to panelists
please just raise your hand and one of
us will promote you
um and uh with the practical matters out
of the way
uh it's a great pleasure to have leslie
valiant here as the speaker
les is very well known for many
contributions i should
mention especially uh the introduction
of the concept of sharp p
completeness and pac learning and
of course many other contributions in
algebraic complexity and circuit
complexity
and other areas as well so uh without
further ado
uh i'll turn the floor over to les he's
speaking on complexity and diversity
okay well thank you very much for the
invitation
so the uh talk is about uh
complexity and its relationship to a
combinatorial property
which i call functional diversity and
this is ongoing work with
ben edelman who is a student at harvard
um so uh
so if you want to understand
computational complexity the very
starting point
and i think your program is about uh
sat so it celebrates the good np
question
and rightly so because that was the
first formulation of
this class of problems about natural
completeness classes
um so that's uh certainly one thing one
can
work on to understand complexity so
another thing one can work on which
i've much trying to promote is
is working on algebraic uh versions of
this
like permanent versus the determinant
and the argument here is that
um if you believe in negative results
then
this should be easier to prove than p
not equal to np
and also that there's a wealth of
potential approaches
to this which are algebraic geometric
and many approaches which in the boolean
world maybe
do not exist but this talk is motivated
by an intermediate
question which is about working on
on more modular counting so question is
whether
the analog of np where you count the
number of solutions
modulo say prime number q um
[Music]
how the complete problems for that
relate to p
and uh and complete problems for this
are np np
is reusable to complete problems in
these now the uh
reason for my interest in this is that
um mainly that there are some
opportunities for negative results which
don't seem to appear
in the other two formulations in
particular
a piece for a restricted model there is
a low band bound argument which
i've been you know interesting for a
long time
um and uh and its main
attraction is that it's very simple it's
a classical mix of algebra and counting
and it's there it's available um it's
useful in this
domain of a for a restricted model
and uh um
[Music]
you know so it's just the availability
of a lower bound argument which isn't
available anywhere else i think is the
main
attraction for this and
this notion of functional diversity is
the way to
approach it okay so so functional
diversity is a very classical looking
property is basically how many
sub functions a function has
so if i give you a function of
of m arguments and
we can look at the boolean case uh or
other cases but if say a and b
are finite
um the issue is um if i fix a
domain of the of the uh of the
variables say the first n how many sub
functions
how many functions how many sub
functions does f have
of the first n variables if i fix the
remaining variables
and uh so this is uh very classical
because
uh it goes back at least to natchez
baruch
in 1963 who who proved um
lower bands on buddha formula complexity
based on essentially this uh property
except that um so he had he
uh partitioned the the variables
formed a partition maybe into root n
sets of root n and then
found the average number of sub
functions you can get
of this set of root n as you vary the
other
remaining variables whereas
um here i'm just looking at the worst
case you know is is there a set of
uh variables maybe log n which has a lot
of um
[Music]
um
which has a lot of sub functions on it
as you vary the
remaining variables um
so of course network could prove low
band up to about quadratic size
for formula size this way um
so just to
pin down the definition slightly more um
so i've got a i've got a function um
usually a
function and i have a what i call a
domain a subset of the variables of size
n
and then the diversity of this domain
the subset of the variables in f
will be the logarithm to the base two
the number of different functions of the
uh of the
of these variables as we fix the
remaining
variables okay
and uh so then we say that the end
diversity
of uh of f
is the worst case is for the worst case
domain d of size n
okay so um so each domain may
uh have different number of sub
functions on it and among the domains of
say login size which is the domain which
has the most functions on it
[Music]
and then we say that a function family
has
say polynomial diversity
if um
the end diversities of its members are
upper bounded by some polynomial
so it's a number of functions this says
the number of functions you can get on a
domain of size n
is um the most single exponential
in the in the end okay so the
the domain of size n the function we
have m variables
so this point i'm not even telling you
know the
the there's no band on how many
variables
the function may have but in fact the
useful version
is that i talk about standard diversity
if the
[Music]
number of variables is most single
exponential in this domain
otherwise it starts losing interest
and so the way i this is a general
very classical a boolean property and
the way it will become interesting
is that um as if you impose some
restrictions
so i'll have some sort of uh plain
structure
and these variables will occur on the
outer periphery
and that's the context image one can
prove useful things about this
but just for a second let's just forget
about this and just
look at this as some basic func basic uh
property of boolean functions um well
the obvious observations are that some
easy functions do have exponential
diversity
and namely which you get from the fact
that the
double exponentially many boolean
functions so if you have a
[Music]
string of n plus two to the n bits
and the first n bits are the variables
and the remaining two to ten bits
specify the truth table for a boolean
function
f um then
by so that the i th
um bit and this tail
is the value of um of the boolean
function
at the eighth value of of
zero one to the n this is just a generic
kabulian uh truth table
since they're two to two three and a
functions um
you can represent every boolean function
like this so um
so on the first log n bits
um you can have uh
double exponentially many functions
which means it's got exponential
diversity
okay and an equivalent thing is is the
circuit value problem
but then instead of have specifying the
boolean function by
a table you specify it by
description of a circuit
now some slightly more natural problems
also encode uh
these tables so for example context-free
recognition
also has high diversity um
again this goes back to early
investigations of uh
related network groups ideas
is that if you've got a context-free
language where you've got a string
and a constant a string and a constant
[Music]
and the question is whether the first
string is found
somewhere else um and
it won't be other w's then
um this is
in reverse then
this is a context-free language because
you can put this into a stack
and non-deterministically go anywhere
and check whether
whether the some other w is the same
thing in reverse
but with this you can you can program in
exactly this boolean function value
problem
you you list all the w's which for which
the function is one
okay so some functions are exponential
diversity
um in fact uh i i these are simple but
you know i don't really know good or
good a different argument for proving
functions to
exponential diversity or i'm sure many
are um
and so basic theme will be can this be
computed by linear algebra
um so um some functions are of
low diversity uh parity um you know so
if you have
a number of variables at the beginning
the dependence on the remaining
variables is just one bit of information
a graph connectivity a similar kind of
thing
that if you've got in the right
representation
[Music]
the if you look at the small part of the
graph the information which you need
about the
enormous unseen path of the graph it's
just following a polynomial
number of bits of information about the
connectivity it imposes
and then a few other things which you
can find in the literature
so for example uh 2cnf
has a similar property that if you've
got some enormous two cnr formula
then the number of functions you can
make up of
of it is is bounded
in a similar way okay
um okay so um but as a general
uh boolean function uh
uh um this the
the diversity of building function is
highly
um representation dependent
so this is uh an observation of ben
adelman
that any boolean function you can recode
um to have polynomial in polynomial time
to have linear diversity
and um i see pavel put luck in the
audience so this is a
simplification of an idea he once
proposed to me a long time ago
and the construction for ben's
construction is simply
that
[Music]
so if you have a say function of
of high diversity then
if you simply repeat the input
um if you've got a input of size
k and you repeat it k times
um and the function you give value zero
if the input isn't a repetition exactly
k times of an input
then this will load this will make the
function have low diversity
okay so um so what i'm saying here is
that
so you've got a function f sub uh
um
okay so yeah so so basically
he's got an arbitrary problem like any
complete problem
if you repeat the input k times
if we repeat the input of size kk times
and for instances which
inputs which don't have that
representation you give the value zero
then this will be a function of the same
complexity
as your previous one but in fact you can
show that this diversity is
destroyed okay so
um okay so um so i've got this very
simple
function property which is in fact
rather brittle
as far as representation so what is it
what
is it useful for of course another
warning is that from
raspberry rudige our argument is that we
shouldn't look for
[Music]
you shouldn't expect too much as fast
complexity
from sim from explicit boolean functions
and that's true but so here i'll use it
as some sort of thinking tool for
analyzing the power of
computational methods
and just another throwaway comment is
that um
another kind of motivation for this kind
of properties is that
certain counting dichotomies which are
important results obtained
in the last
[Music]
decade or so the complexity dichotomies
and it's always an interesting question
whether these dichotomies coincide with
some
simple combinatorial property and
[Music]
and don't need to be expressed in terms
of computation
okay so um so the main point here is
that there is a
lower bound argument somewhere
and uh the lower bound argument is a
simple combination of counting
which is simply as in shannon when he
showed that most boolean functions are
applied complexity
and the other aspect of these proofs is
that it's simple linear algebra
and these are by linear algebra i mean
the grassmann pucker or greater than it
is
which i'll come to in a second and so
just to explain
the algebra that's used so the idea
simply is that if you have a matrix
then you can talk about
subsets of the rows and subsets of the
columns so s and t
will be subsets of rows and columns and
x of s comma t will be a determinant
will be the determinant of this matrix
with these rows and columns deleted
okay so given a matrix this is notation
for talking about the determinant of sub
matrices
[Music]
and on these subject of these
sub-determinants of
matrix uh there are some identities
okay so a trivial one for this is that
so this means that
so this means that this is a matrix x
with no rows and no columns
deleted so this means the determinant of
this matrix
this means all the rows and all the
columns are
deleted and this is one
so they said the determinant of this
matrix is equal to
and of course this is if you delete row
one and row two you get
just just this element so you can
imagine you can make up a
just the formula for the determinant of
a 2x2 matrix
gives you an identity in the axis
but it turns out that uh there's a
plethora of identities or matrices
and the grassman and pluta relations
you should look at you've got a matrix
and an n is some is the number of rows
and columns you select
we could pick n n equal to three
and these relations will relate uh
the determinants of sub matrices of
these which you get
by deleting subsets of the first three
rows and columns
okay so n is the
rows and columns which you select from
to delete
and then the mixed matrix can be of any
size
and so you do get an exponential number
of such identities
in terms of the n and the
interesting thing is that these
identities hold
indepen independent for all matrices so
these uh
other you know the size of matrix
doesn't even enter
so uh subject determinants of subjects
some determinants of matrices have very
lots of identities um
now for us this is uh
a constraint so we like determines
because we can
compute them easily but all these
relations are an impediment
to how expressive they are
um so in holographic algorithms we
attempt to build gates
uh with the properties of the of these
identities
um which i'll show in a second
and so unfortunately
the grasp and proof identities relate to
the actual subdeterminants
but for
using them for holographic algorithms we
don't
get exactly sub determinants we'll get
sub determinants but they'll have
different different
signs so the signs are messed up
but fortunately these uh
the way the signs are messed up um can
be compensated for
because um the
sub determinants we need with a chain
signed
we change signs as it turns out
uh hold similar properties and these are
called the match grade identities
and the last word on on them
is this by ty and gorenstein
which is the result of a long
sequence of of previous papers
okay so the um
so linear algebra type type constraints
hold
um for these things okay
so just to remind you what these match
gates are
so the idea is that we'll see we'll
simulate
boolean properties by a bits of linear
algebra
so this is a little graph it will be a
gate and
this is this is the adjacency matrix no
sorry size it's not the adjacency matrix
not sorry
um so what we're interested in
is the matching polynomial of this
of this of this graph
um so for example
x so matching polynomial is
is the just a product of all the um it's
it's like a it's a product is is the sum
of raw matchings the product of the
weights of the matchings
so if we for example for this whole
matrix
um you have this edge and this edge the
weights are ac
a times c this edge on this edge the
weights are db
and so this is the
[Music]
matching polynomial
for the whole matrix for the whole graph
so this matrix
we do by looking at this what we call a
gate
and um this is this is
this indicates whether we want to
include or exclude the edges on these
input edges
and the output edges so these are the
input these are the output edges so zero
zero zero zero means that these edges
will have an uh will not be matched
so in a complete matching of the graph
you'll have to match the four vertices
internally
that's why you've got acvd
whereas for example this x23
says that you'll match the bottom of the
inputs in the top of the outputs
so if you match the bottom of the input
and the top of the output
then you need this edge e to match the
other vertices
that's where x2 3 will be e
okay so uh so this matrix is like a
matrix of sub determinants
if i skip one or two
niceties and we want to capture boolean
properties
by relations of these of these
values that we get okay
um that's how we get boolean properties
and these are the different terms
um so the goal is that when we assemble
lots of these match gates
then uh we want to be left with a simple
determinant computation
which will account for for you the
number of answers
so the goal is all we can do is compute
determinants our goal is to compute a
big determinant at the end
the hard part is to make up a big graph
where the determinant is of interest
[Music]
and so when assembling these gates there
is a sign problem
and and this is this connection between
um these
match gates which you have to probably
have to overcome but can be overcome
and just to mention that so sometimes in
holographic algorithms one uses this kft
method
the idea that for playing the graphs um
you can put directions on the edges so
that
in effect you make all the components of
the perfect matching polynomial positive
there's one approach another approach is
somehow you
work directly with the raw linear
algebra and you manage the science
directly but in either case you've got
this problem of
that you try to model gates boolean
properties of gates
using uh bits of this perfect matching
polynomial
but to put them together there are some
sign issues
okay so um if i could ask a question
uh yes yeah just on the previous slide
just a simple question wanted to make
sure i understood correctly
the way those perfect matching
polynomials are working you're sort of
thinking
it's almost like you have a gadget you
have this you're talking about the ways
i'm matching the things on the left to
the things on the right
and those are being the entries in the
in in the matrix then um
yeah so exactly this is a gadget and
then you have lots of you
put your big graph you have lots of
these gadgets
and you want the pivot matching
polynomial of the whole thing
to equal what you want to compute it and
and uh these will represent the building
properties
of the gates or properties of the gates
yes yeah that's good thank you okay okay
so then in the end you get you finish up
with some
some big graph which so match grid is
like a
is it's a huge gate one one which
computes value to your problem
so in the end you get a big graph with
some values on the edges
and you won't compute the matching
polynomial of this
okay so that's what you get to by
composing all this
and so basic question is um well can one
compute np comp
np complete problems this way so for
example you can do satisfiability or
planar satisfiability
i want to count the number of solutions
maybe module okay
a modular queue a prime number and of
course all these are
np-hard and sharpie complete problems
so okay so can we do this um
well the answer is that um so what's
provable and this is this
lower bound argument i've been trying to
emphasize
is that if the reduction is
is what i call elementary it's a it's
suitably constrained
then we can prove by the simple argument
that this
is not possible so you can't prove np
complete
mp complete problems by this uh simplest
uh
method um and uh
so essentially what elementary means so
it means it's it's a car production
so from your problem so for example you
have a plane
uh satisfiability problem
and you indeed a gadget in your plane a
satisfactory
problem you have a gadget here and you
hope that the determinant of the whole
thing will um
solve your mp complete problem for you
um so elementary means that um in this
re
so it's a property of of the reduction
um so it means essentially that you do
the obvious things that
each each um component
of your sat problem
you map to a to a local gate
um of the type i've mentioned
um so the main the main restriction is
that it's
the mapping is um from
it's kind of local that each part of the
of the um of the
circuit or formula you're mapping goes
to some local
formula in your match gate okay so um
okay so the definition of of elementary
is is slightly messy but it's uh
you know it does capture what was needed
i believe
and for these um one can show using
um a combination of counting
and uh and this uh
linear algebra that no these direct
uh one-shot evaluations of
the determinant will not solve empty
complete problems for you
okay and
the um
[Music]
okay and it's so it's important that we
we count that we do mod counting because
that
makes it that restricts the number of
possible functions
so that's important for the counting and
the um
and we do need uh the algebra so the
algebra
the the match gate identities are what
we need
to constrain the idea that um if you've
got a bit of your circuit here
and some enormous part of it of the rest
of the circuit
there comes some constraints on what the
stress to the circuit can contribute to
the problem you are trying to solve
if the problem you're trying to solve
has high diversity
okay okay so
that's kind of what you'd expect um but
then
the issue is that um the next step up
so this is the first idea of solving mp
complete problems by linear doesn't work
but the second step is open so what's
the second possible step
well what if we allow our cook
reductions in a particular way
and basically we want coke reductions to
to do polynomial interpolation
so by polynomial interpolation i mean
that in this
match grid i do exactly as i did before
but on some of the edges i put a
indeterminate z and then
if i want to compute an instance of this
problem or size
uh say n psi m
so i've got a boolean for planar pulley
and formula of size m
i draw i construct a huge one of these
somehow size m squared maybe
and so then this will compute a
polynomial in z
and maybe a coefficient of this
polynomial in z
will give me the answer so interpolation
is a very basic tool used in
in translating counting problems um
um so so since like sharpie completeness
proofs
you know use gadgets use some of these
holographic reductions but the third
main technique is
is interpolation so it's a very powerful
tool from going from one country from
to another okay um
so anyway so the question is you know
can one prove uh
you know satisfiability mod q which is
of course mp hard
to be hard by simply
constructing a simple uh a single match
grid
in this indeterminate z and computing a
coefficient of of z
and hoping that that's the answer and
this is
uh this is open and one would think that
there's some simple proof that this
doesn't work but
um there is an interesting construction
of
uh jinyitai which shows that
uh it's not it may not be so easy to
prove that this doesn't work
because interpolation does give you
something in this context
okay so so that's the um main message
um so there's a problem here um
so okay so if i go one more minute
okay so that's the main point um
so then the only other thing i want to
emphasize is that um
two more things one is that although
proving high
diversity um
[Music]
sounded trivial with these
problems compete for p in fact for for
many problems it's you know i don't have
any techniques for showing high
diversity
except somehow for showing that these
pre-complete problems are hidden inside
and the kind of problems of interest
would be this plane this is very simple
counting problems which are on the
boundary of being
easy and hard and so this is
this um
notation for expressing uh combinator
combinatorial properties
so the easing problem so this says that
your problem is made up of
components where um
so these are like this is like a degree
three vertex
and um and
the three signals being sent out uh
either
that no no none of them are uh are ones
or all of them are ones
so the various positions here count how
many of the
of the outputs are ones
[Music]
and so this is a easing problem means
that if
the so this strip models the edges so if
the
two edge ends have different values then
you have a value c
if they're the same they have value one
so this is an easing problem and in
general we don't know whether these have
high or low diversity
except for very odd places for very odd
values of
of the of this constant one can show it
by essentially showing that
you can map the
circuit value problems into it um
and similarly for like planar matchings
uh you like to show no nobody's got
higher low complexity
highly low diversity but again it can it
can be shown for example for some very
odd uh
fields of size 19 for example again
because you can buy accident map
complete problems anyway so that's not
so the main point is that there's big
this big open problem
but just as a to finish off
the philosophical note on holographic
algorithms um
[Music]
so okay so this is saying that
traditional complexity what do what do
we do
when traditional complexity we build
things up
we have uh and gate organs not case fan
out
and see what we can make out of these
components
but then at the end we say oh we've got
this big problem with non-determine
non-determinism
what on earth do we do about that okay
so in holographic algorithms we we
reverse this
so we say well we want to do we want to
be able to solve non-determinism so we
build in linear algebra which does solve
a kind of non-determinism
but then what we're left with is saying
well what can we build up inside it what
functionality can we
do non-determinism over
and maybe it's not surprising that
of course we can't uh if we could
simulate all of
standard computation then we could prove
equals mp but we can't so we tried to
see what fragment
of of this we can simulate and so
perhaps it's not surprising that this
basic
capability of doing um
of doing you know deterministic
compilation the circuit value problem is
kind of uh
is critical okay
so thank you
very much uh great very interesting talk
uh
and let me i'm i'm gonna clap for behalf
of everybody here since they can't clap
and
want to open the floor to
to questions and so on um
maybe while people are formulating their
questions let me just ask you you would
you talked about holographic
algorithms uh but didn't really define
them did you want to
say a few words about what they are for
well i i just kind of uh well there were
many facets
to them uh um
well one way of looking at them is what
i tried to explain that um
depends where you started as one level
this holographic idea
is is an idea about about reductions
okay and
but here i've emphasized that if you
want to use them for use for
useful algorithms when you reduce you
better start with something you know how
to do
so in this case you start with um
the linear algebra because they're fast
outcomes for it and in epic
particular uh using linear algebra for
solving
uh playing a certain plane of problems
like the
um um fkt algorithm
for perfect matching and playing the
graphs is a good way to start so
that's how i uh i refer to it okay so
are very various ways in which you can
uh present holographic algorithms
i kind of hinted at one right
okay and and how important is the
planarity
property um
so um
okay so
um okay so in so the basic
question that if you want to reduce
things to
linear algebra you know you have to you
have to model the individual individual
gates
and then you have to put them together
so that's that
when you've done all that is still in
algebra
[Music]
so so one of the two
approaches which i mentioned is this is
using this
known fact that planar
perfect matchings you can do in
polynomial time
so this so in the planar case
uh casterlane 50 years ago gave a method
for
making for making the composition of the
gates automatic
okay so plane is important if you want
to use this method of
of doing the composition in a kind of
automated way
but in the end what you're always doing
is linear algebra
and it's actually it's you're working
through
farfields so the other approach is to uh
use fraufenians directly
um and in in that case it's you have to
handle the uh
signs so in that case you don't have to
say
anything explainer but uh
in the end the kind of things you do are
largely equivalent
okay so so in the end ultimately
the two approaches look very similar so
whether this only works for pain
structures or not is uh um
isn't totally clear but that's at some
from
some bird's eye view
[Music]
maybe yes but maybe not
okay all right um
so let me let me open the floor to
general questions uh either
post questions into the chat windows if
you wish and i'll read them back
or just unmute yourself and
ask a question is fine too so of course
some questions or comments
um i i may have missed it so so
you going back to this uh page with the
the different kinds of reductions in
your uh open question
uh your big open question um i
i why is the i i
why is the diversity this polynomial uh
diversity versus exponential diversity
exactly why how does sort of on a
technical level is that connection
uh work with them with the model uh
um well
it's uh um
at an intuitive level really it's more
than
yeah so it's um um
so so basically it's if this initial
picture you've got your
few inputs and potentially so if you
if hidden away there's a circuit value
problem there
and and and the function of this
say an input could be any of double
exponentially many
then the problem is that the way these
inputs are connected to the rest of your
problem um
is is it has a little like a bottleneck
in it so linear algebra is like a
bottleneck
it it restricts to where you can
communicate is login inputs
i see i see
and and that doesn't follow
incarcerating the cook reduction context
that intuition
fails in that context uh
for i well what's the reason for that
yeah well they proved
the proof fails um um
well well because um one thing is that
once once you
uh do a quick reduction then
effectively you you you you
you you repeat the inputs uh lots of
times so they look you haven't localized
inputs anymore i see so that that
argument that
that linear uh diversity argument that
uh
burn elements that you uh reference
would essentially come into play
right right right so the whole so this
diversities
it's hard to do if the if the inputs are
kind of local and
they're not replicated millions of times
well if they put to represent everywhere
then the argument falls apart
i see i see thanks okay okay
good question okay
okay
other questions or comments
um
give people a chance
well okay maybe not uh thank you
somebody last chance or questions or
comments um
okay otherwise thank you again for a
very nice talk and for uh
showing places where we can get more
bounds i guess and so forth so that's
that's good so appreciate it very much
so thank you again
okay thanks for inviting me thank you
thank you all right bye bye so this is
our only speaker this morning so uh
we'll end early today so uh thank you
very much
okay
thanks liz that was that was good
appreciate you come